i'm alexander rose i'm the executive
director here at the long now foundation
it is really great to have you all in
real life give yourself a round of
applause for showing up thank you
[Applause]
edward or ted slingerland he's spoken
for us before originally when he was at
the center for advanced behavioral
studies at stanford
since that time and around and through
pandemic started researching the
basically that where where history where
civilization and alcohol combine and his
research was very much along the lines
of when we started this place here at
the interval of trying to figure out how
civilization and drinking
tea coffee as well as as alcohol um has
really affected the way that we come
together in a social space
and he's his original training was in
chinese philosophy but he's presently
in the philosophy department at the
university of british columbia and i'd
really love to welcome edward
slingerland
thank you
cheers everyone
gross
so people like to masturbate
they also like to eat twinkies and do
shots of jagermeister not typically all
at the same time but
if you had a rough week no one's going
to judge
what these otherwise disparate pleasures
have in common
is that from a scientific perspective
we've been told they're all evolutionary
mistakes
so let's talk about masturbation
the orgasm is the best thing that can
happen to you
right evolution is reserving its biggest
carrot its biggest reward for the
behavior that it wants to reward the
most which is putting genes into the
next generation so this is typic the the
adaptive target of the orgasm is
reproductive sex
human beings being very clever primates
have figured out we can get this reward
other ways right so this is a classic
case of a brain hijack so this is one
type of evolutionary mistake where you
are getting a reward that you're not
supposed to get you're getting a reward
you're figuring out a way to trigger a
reward circuit that shouldn't be
triggered in the situation you're in
evolution designed this very powerful
positive reinforcement device and human
beings have figured out how to game the
system and other animals as well like
little rats pushing a lever to get
cocaine injections evolution's probably
kind of pissed off about this but it
it's not going to bother with it very
much because masturbation is a pretty
low cost behavior it's low cost and it's
also really not interfering at the end
of the day with the main objective we're
still doing plenty of reproductive sex
twinkies junk food in general is a
different type of evolutionary mistake
i'm going to call this an evolutionary
mismatch so this is a case where there
was an adaptive target but it doesn't
apply anymore so for most of our
evolutionary history
we food was a problem acquiring enough
food was a problem especially sweet
things and proteins fatty types of
things were a very patchy resource so
you get a lot of it all at once and then
you get nothing for a long time
so
individuals who had a sweet tooth and
who liked fat and who would gorge on
this stuff when they had it had an
advantage this is a very adaptive trait
and for most of our evolutionary history
evolution is not going to care not
really be able to deal with this at all
because it's a very recent problem and
it's still pretty localized so there's
lots of places in the world where
getting enough calories is still a
challenge so evolution is not going to
worry about this mismatch problem too
much in the case of junk food
now when it comes to alcohol the
aegermeister shots
we've been told the standard story is
that it's a brain hijack that's the most
dominant scientific theory about why we
have a taste for alcohol we figured out
that consuming ethanol triggers this
reward network in our brain and like
that little rat pushing the lever we
just keep doing it that's the standard
story there are also various mismatch
theories floating around out there that
tastes for alcohol allowed us to consume
liquid in a safe form when water was
contaminated there are several different
mismatched theories what i want to argue
tonight is none of these make sense none
of these can actually be an explanation
for an evolutionary explanation for why
we have a taste for alcohol and that's
because our taste for intoxication is
ancient costly and dangerous as as long
as we've had writing
people have been complaining about the
dangers of alcohol the dangers of
alcoholism the dangers of social chaos
caused by excessive consumption we find
this in ancient egypt ancient china
in ancient sumer it's estimated that
half the grain production went to
producing beer so they're taking half of
their food and turning it into liquid
neurotoxins and as you notice you know
kings had to decree that their subjects
weren't allowed to make more beer than a
certain amount because people want to
turn it into beer so very costly in
terms of social consequences and also
just materially costly economically
costly it's estimated that today
most households spend about a third of
their food and beverage budget on
alcohol and that's almost certainly an
underestimate because of black markets
and under reporting
and you may have not gotten the memo yet
about masturbation it doesn't make you
go blind
don't worry about it
what does make you go blind is alcohol
shots of jagermeister it can make you go
blind so it's very alcohol is very
damaging physiologically it causes liver
damage it raises your cancer risk from a
medical perspective there's really no
upside to alcohol and you can forget
about all this the french paradox
cholesterol stuff it's
it's bad for you from a biomedical
perspective alcohol is bad for you it's
a dangerous substance
in the tiny country that i live in now
about the size of
california 2014 is estimated that the
economic impact of alcohol abuse was
14.6 billion dollars that's probably
canadian dollars that's like ten dollars
u.s but still a lot of
um fourteen thousand eight hundred
deaths eighty seven hundred hospital
admissions all these years of productive
life loss this is if this is an
evolutionary mistake it's an incredibly
costly evolutionary mistake it doesn't
make sense that there would not be some
pressure to fix this if all it was
was a cost now sometimes it is the case
that evolution can't fix something so
evolution is constrained by certain
conditions so evolution can't act on a
variant that doesn't exist selection
pressure can't select for a genetic
variation that isn't out in the world
yet so it's possible that our
taste for alcohol is a mistake it's a
very costly ancient dangerous one but
genetic evolution just hasn't churned
out their variant yet that would fix the
problem that's one possibility there are
also various types of what's called path
dependence where evolution makes one
decision and then it's kind of stuck it
has to keep going down that path so that
could be part of the story too it's not
neither of those is possible in this
case because there are genetic and
cultural solutions to the problem of
intoxication that evolution could have
taken advantage of if it wanted to so
let's talk about the genetic one first
there is a set of two different
mutations in enzymes that have to do
with the processing of alcohol in the
body that lead to a syndrome that's
sometimes called asian flushing syndrome
because it's most common in east asia
if you have this syndrome a couple sips
of alcohol your face turns red you start
to flush you feel nauseous drinking
alcohol is very unpleasant if you have
this this genetic condition
if alcohol were just a costly mistake
this is the solution to the problem this
is awesome it's actually so effective at
helping with drinking that a chemical
that reproduces the effects of this
genetic syndrome is used to treat
alcoholism because you just don't like
to drink so there is this genetic
solution out there and it's an ancient
one so it's estimated that this evolved
seven to ten thousand years ago
somewhere around present-day shanghai
but it just sits there this is present
distribution focused around its origin
spread a little bit to japan and korea
but it's pretty much sat there it's also
very interesting that analogous
mutations causing the same effect have
evolved at least twice independently
once in the middle east and once in
europe and also remain very confined to
limited populations
so this is the silver bullet to the
problem of our taste for alcohol and yet
it hasn't done anything it hasn't spread
very much that suggests that there's
there's more to the story here than just
some kind of evolutionary mistake
let's talk about cultural evolution
which is very powerful cultural
evolution can fix things very quickly
it's very good at responding to new
situations
how would cultural evolution deal with
the problem of a mistaken taste for
alcohol
pretty easy just tell people they can't
drink
right it's not it's not rocket science
so prohibition we tend to think of
prohibition
in the american context but again
anywhere
there have been human beings who can
write we have records of prohibition in
ancient china one of the earliest law
statutes that we have
decrees death to anyone who makes or
consumes alcohol
it didn't work it was about as
successful as american prohibition was
there are major world religions that are
based on prohibition one of their main
uh tenants is uh abstaining from things
that are intoxicating to the mind so
this the solution culturally is out
there and yet like that genetic solution
it just kind of sits there so this is
where alcohol is currently prohibited in
in part or in whole in the world it
looks a lot like that genetic map it
didn't disappear the solution maintains
in our genetic and cultural repertoire
but it kind of sits there it doesn't
spread the way you would expect it to
spread if this was really only a problem
if there were only costs involved with
alcohol you would expect both this gene
complex and this cultural idea of just
prohibiting alcohol to spread very
quickly and it hasn't
so this is the puzzle this is why
alcohol is puzzling to someone who looks
at human behavior through an
evolutionary lens so we have these
very real costs social physiological
costs
we have both genetic and cultural
evolutionary solutions to these costs
that haven't taken off
the only conclusion you can come to if
you're looking at this through an
evolutionary lens
is that there are benefits on the other
side there's something that is on the
other side of the equation that's
keeping our taste for alcohol both in
our gene pool and in our cultural
repertoires
so that's what we got to look at is what
the benefits might be
what it can't but the benefits can't be
is pleasure
or happiness the answer can't be it
makes us feel good because evolution
doesn't care whether we feel good or not
the answer's got to be something
adaptive something in the currency that
evolution works in um so so we have to
think about what the potential adaptive
benefits of alcohol are to think about
that we have to think about our
particular ecological niche so human
beings are primates but we're really
weird primates um we're very our
lifestyles and
everything about us is very different
from our closest relatives i want to
focus on two things in particular
one of them is our dependence on
technology
tool sets and therefore innovation we
are completely human beings are
completely dependent on technology so
much so that so one of the most ancient
technologies is fire we're so dependent
on fire that our digestive system our
jaws our teeth have changed we actually
can't consume raw food only anymore we
need it pre-digested by cooking we're so
dependent on this technology cooking
that our bodies have changed to adapt to
the technology so humans are like this
we're incredibly dependent on tools if
you're dependent on tools you're
dependent on creativity and innovation
the environment's constantly changing
you're having you have to adapt your
tool sets to new situations
you're competing with other cultural
groups who maybe have better tool sets
than you and can exploit the environment
more effectively than you can
so if you're using tools if you're
dependent on tools you're dependent on
creativity and innovation so that's one
part of our weird ecological niche it's
creativity
an interesting fact about human
creativity is human adults are not very
creative
human children are
so alison gopnik psychologist at uc
berkeley has done this great work with
these very clever
experiments where she's measuring
lateral thinking so type of creativity
where you need to have an insight you
can't kind of power your way through it
through a b c reasoning you have to see
something new and she has these very
clever blicket detector experiments
where she measures this and what she's
found is that actually four-year-olds
are awesome at these tasks they can
detect these kind of counter-intuitive
things and our ability to do so just
decreases linearly
with age as as we get older so by the
time we're adults we're much worse at
these kind of thinking outside the box
tasks than four-year-olds are
why is that
in the book i actually lay this next to
another graph which is the maturation of
a certain part of the brain called the
prefrontal cortex
so the the villain here seems to be the
prefrontal cortex it's the last part of
the brain to mature it doesn't fully
mature until we're in our 20s and it
seems to be
part of the problem with creativity so
so why is that the prefrontal cortex is
very important part of the brain it's
very expensive we wouldn't have it if it
wasn't doing something important
it's the center of cognitive control
it's what allows us to control our
impulses to
focus on things it allows us to
pursue a task and and spend time on it
not to get distracted by other things
it's what allows us to delay
gratification so we can resist
temptations in the moment or laziness in
the moment to do something that's more
long-term
you need to have a fully functioning
prefrontal cortex to be a successful
adult it's a really crucial part of our
machinery and yet it seems to interfere
with lateral thinking
and the idea is kind of the pfc allows
you to focus
but by causing you to focus in a
laser-like way you're not you're not
seeing things in the periphery that
children are constantly distracted by
right drives you crazy when you're a
grown up but that's what kids are
constantly just seeing everything and
that's why they can't focus we need to
focus so evolution's got this problem
we can't remain
like children our whole lives we have to
become adults we have to be able to tie
our shoes and get to school on time and
and do the things that adults do
but it comes at a cost
it comes at the cost of this this kind
of creativity we have when we're
four-year-olds
what would be awesome is if we could
remain adults with all the capabilities
we have as adults all the knowledge that
we have as adults but every once in a
while turn back the clock a bit
and try to think like a four-year-old
again so to do that you'd have to undo
that maturation of prefrontal cortex at
least temporarily you could down
regulate it for instance so one way you
could do this is a transcranial magnet
and people
people have done this um you zap the
prefrontal cortex with a magnet take it
offline temporarily and people do better
at lateral thinking tests they get they
go back up to kind of where kids are and
the performance on these tasks so this
is great this shows you that the pfc is
the problem right it's what's getting in
in the way of our creativity the problem
is this is a relatively recent
technology it's bulky it's expensive if
you showed up at a party with this
they wouldn't let you in right
so what would be better than the
transcranial magnet
is a technology that's a little more
subtle lower tech you can make it out of
anything it's easy to discover it pairs
well with food maybe you see where i'm
going um alcohol is is that technology
alcohol is our low-tech transcranial
magnet that can take out the pfc and so
alcohol has a lot of different effects
um the the journalist stephen brown has
called it a
pharmacological hand grenade it just
kind of goes in and starts hitting all
the buttons at once it's really it's a
it's a messy drug
um so it is in various timings and ways
it simulates the effects of meth and
cocaine prozac
valium opium is doing all these things
and at various points as you as your bac
increases but crucially and what's going
to be crucial for the story i'm telling
today
is that it depresses the prefrontal
cortex it depresses the motor cortex as
well which is why you shouldn't drive
and you have trouble speaking at a
certain point of inebriation but
crucially it's down regulating that that
part of our brain temporarily and and
the nice thing is it does it gently it
does it predictably and it does it with
pretty um uh short uh half-life you you
recover very quickly so it's actually a
brilliant technology for for taking the
pfc offline temporarily and what does
that give you gives you creativity
so this there's this association you see
across the world throughout history
of creative types artists writers poets
with alcohol you see it in ancient china
you see it in the ancient mideast you
see it in the present day this is not a
myth there actually is a very good
reason why alcohol is associated with
creativity and artists it's because it
actually does make us more creative by
down regulating the prefrontal cortex
now in terms of direct evidence of this
there's not a whole lot right now this
is a nice study i like by michael
andrews looking at correlation
he's taking advantage he's an economist
and he took advantage of this great
natural experiment american prohibition
so we tend to think of prohibition as
something that happened all at once at
the federal level just suddenly no one
america could drink and it wasn't like
that at all it actually took a really
long time to impose prohibition and it
was imposed piecemeal at the county
level so he was able to look at county
level data and what he was looking at
was patent applications as a as a proxy
for innovation and he could look at
patent applications at the county level
and what he saw is that when you impose
prohibition on a county patent
applications plunge
collective innovation plunges and then
it slowly recovers it took about three
years to get back to pre-prohibition
levels
he his hypothesis is speakeasies
is why that happened so basically
prohibition comes in you can't drink
socially anymore
innovation goes down and it goes down
until people figure out a workaround and
the workaround was figuring out a new
way to drink socially so social drinking
seems to be related to innovation group
innovation in this sense there's also
one nice direct study that shows that
this is actually not just correlational
it's causation that if you take subjects
and you give them a real alcoholic drink
as opposed to a fake alcoholic drink
they're more creative and their
creativity peaks at about .08 so that's
about when you have a nice buzz on when
you shouldn't operate a motor vehicle
but that seems to be the spot where you
still have enough cognitive control to
actually think coherently and do things
that are useful but you've been loosened
up the hold of the pfc has been loosened
upon you in a certain way
so creativity is one of the really
important functions
of alcohol
another strange thing about us compared
to other primates
is that we are communal we're dependent
on other people in a way that no other
primate is and to get anything useful
done we need to trust one another we
need to engage in long-term cooperative
tasks that require trust and when we
embark upon these tasks we run into
various types of cooperation dilemmas
and these go under different types of
names prisoners dilemma tragedy of the
commons
they have the same structure though
you get the best payoff if you trust and
you cooperate the problem is this is a
crucial part of the structure of these
dilemmas i don't know in advance whether
or not you're going to cooperate with me
and if you don't cooperate if you defect
as economists put it i'm screwed
i get zero you get a great payoff and so
for a rational self-interested agent in
a prisoner's dilemma game the only
strategy is to defect so everyone
defects and everybody gets that kind of
bummer mutual defection outcome in real
life people solve this all the time we
we're constantly solving prisoners
dilemmas in our real life and we do it
because we're not rational
self-interested agents we're emotional
and we use emotions to help us solve
these dilemmas we have emotions like
honor like loyalty like trust that allow
us that bind us to each other in a
certain way that prevent defections from
happening so emotions the economist
robert frank has a great book called
passions within reason where he explains
that these love and honor and these
things they're approximately irrational
so in in your actual psychology they're
not rational but they have this kind of
long-term rationality on an evolutionary
scale
so so we use these emotions and because
emotions help us cooperate we use them
as cues to know who's a good cooperator
and who's not so when we're deciding
whether or not to trust someone we look
at their emotional expressions this is
the safety net we have in cooperation
i meet you and you genuinely are happy
to meet you how do i know you're you're
genuinely happy because you have that
smile on the left and not the one on the
right the left one is a duchenne smile
completely different muscle system
not under typically under voluntary
control that's the smile you make when
you're
serving people in a restaurant or
something you have to be nice to them
we like the one of the left we don't
like the one on the right
so we use emotional displays as a way to
know whether or not to trust people
this this opens up this this possible
risk though that people could be faking
it
the soft spot here again is a prefrontal
cortex in order to lie in order to cheat
in order to calculate you need your
prefrontal cortex in top shape um lying
is very difficult cognitively right you
have to keep in track in your mind both
what's true and what's what you're
telling the person you have to suppress
emotions that have to do with the false
thing that you're not telling them about
it's it's real you need your pfc in top
shape
what's also interesting is uh when the
pfc is in top shape we're not as good at
detecting lies and this seems to be
because we look at when we're
consciously focusing on detecting lies
we're not very good at it we look at the
wrong things it's only when we're
relaxed that we actually take in more
information so let's target the
prefrontal cortex with what with our
good old friend alcohol
down regulates the prefrontal cortex it
makes us hard it makes it harder for us
to lie it makes us easier for us to
detect lies and it's also simultaneously
boosting some hormones like serotonin
that make us less likely to cheat so
it's it's enhancing these kind of
pro-social hormones in human beings so
this is why um you know when when people
potentially hostile adults meet and have
to come to some kind of agreement they
shake hands and they're showing i'm not
carrying a weapon
when you meet with someone and you do a
couple of shots
you're saying i no longer have a
prefrontal cortex i am cognitively
disarming
and putting my prefrontal cortex on the
table you can trust me this is why
from ancient china to ancient greece
alcohol is always at the center of
banquets of treaty negotiations anything
where you have people with potentially
differing interests having to agree on
something
all the way up to you know nixon told
his chinese counterpart if we drank
enough mao tai we could do anything
right this idea that if we just disarm
cognitively we can solve these problems
and people use this informally all the
time so a cocktail party a mixer you're
having to meet new people
you want to cognitively disarm so we're
simultaneously decreasing our
inhibitions and increasing these kind of
pro-social chemicals that help us like
each other like ourselves more and like
each other's more so alcohol plays this
really important tool
in helping people
bond and helping people cooperate this
is also why when when skype was invented
remember back then
everyone predicted business travel would
disappear right why would you get on a
plane and fly to shanghai
if you could just you know skype with
these people to sign a contract and yet
people kept getting on planes and flying
to shanghai until the pandemic it took a
global pandemic to shut down business
travel and this is because if you're
going to enter into any kind of
significant deal with another group of
people you want to sit down and get
drunk with them and eat a meal with them
to get a sense of who they are for real
so this is one of the important
functions of alcohol
so in in drunk i walk through
these functional and important benefits
of alcohol but the important point is
that
you don't want to admit you don't want
to lose sight of the cost of alcohol
it's a dangerous substance
it's estimated that up to 15 percent of
the human population is prone to
alcoholism and if you have a tendency to
alcoholism you can't drink safely so
it's a dangerous substance it can lead
to all sorts of chaos
but the taste for alcohol has been
preserved in our species because there
are these countervailing benefits this
is a carving that's 20 000 years old
from southwest france it's called the
venus of lausanne
and she is holding up a drinking horn
and throwing throwing it back
it's not water
this isn't direct evidence that people
are drinking but it's the earliest
pretty strong indirect evidence that
people are producing and consuming
alcohol people have been producing and
consuming alcohol for as long as we've
been doing anything in an organized way
as a species
it's the old story used to be that we
discovered agriculture and then kind of
as a mistake we stumbled upon alcohol so
we left the sourdough starter out for
too long started to ferment we tasted it
and thought it was good it looks like
it's actually the other way around so
the so-called beer before bread
hypothesis which has been gaining in
adherence and evidence
argues that it was actually a taste for
alcohol that drove us
to start agriculture in the first place
and people who are advancing this idea
look at things like this so twenty
thousand years ago is way before
agriculture we also have sites like this
one gobekli tepe so this is in
present-day turkey
ten to twelve thousand years ago you
have 100 gatherers again thousands of
years before agriculture gathering
together creating this monumental
religious architecture and having these
massive banquets with with huge amounts
of wild game and then drinking something
out of these huge vats that we've
discovered and we don't have chemical
residues from these particular bass but
we know that people in the region were
making beer
they were making beer we had direct
evidence that's as old as 13 000 years
ago from present-day israel
and often beer mixed with hallucinogens
so that's why you get carvings like this
dancing turtles you don't get that from
drinking water right
so
it this is the sense in which there's a
there's a literal direct sense in which
intoxication has led to civilization
it's the desire to get intoxicated that
caused human beings to start to settle
down and live in agricultural
communities and you see this not just in
the fertile crescent but all over the
world
the first cultivated plants seem to be
chosen for their psychoactive properties
not for nutrition so it really is this
this desire to alter our mind that
caused us to settle down in societies
for the for the first point so this is
why you look at any culture around the
world there's alcohol and if there's not
alcohol there's something functionally
similar so in places where they don't
have alcohol not many places in the
world but there are some they have
substances like cava
cannabis they have hallucinogen infused
tobacco that are serving exactly the
same functions people are sitting down
and consuming these things at banquets
and and treaty meetings and and points
where the pfc needs to get down
regulated and socially bonding hormones
need to get up related so so there's a
real sense in which uh intoxication
and civilization have been intertwined
from the very beginning so i want to
talk a little bit about the dangers of
alcohol as well the the gift of dionysus
is an important one but we have to see
that they sometimes aren't what they
seemed at first for all of the functions
that i i talk about in the book the
social bonding
reducing inhibitions there are dark
sides as well
tribalism
people being disinhibited who really
shouldn't be disinhibited you would like
to be using their prefrontal cortex a
bit more happy sociality can can very
quickly turn into violence and
aggression and that's why alcohol is
implicated in domestic violence and all
sorts of of really negative consequences
for society
so alcohol is dangerous we also have to
keep in mind that it's more dangerous
now than it's ever been if we want to
think in long now ways about the big
picture
right now at this moment we're at a very
dangerous point with our relationship
with alcohol and that's because alcohol
has always come with two safety features
that have recently been disabled so one
of them is the natural limits on the
strength of alcoholic beverages if
you're using natural fermentation
alcohol can only get so strong
very very recently again in the long
view humans figured out to make how to
make this stuff distilled liquor this
stuff is so powerful it really should be
considered a different drug it's it you
can get up to like 90 something abv with
distillation so it's still ethanol but
it's at a level just a dosage that we
are not built to deal with so this is a
dangerous thing and it's very recent so
our history with alcohol goes back at
least 10 million years when our primate
ancestors adapted to eating fruit that
contained some alcohol here's modern
humans emerging 200 000 years ago
certainly by 12 000 years ago we were
making beer and maybe wines
that's when distillation happens
a few hundred years ago
and that sounds like a long time ago you
know 1600 sounds like a long time ago
it's a blink of an eye and on the time
scale we're talking about we just
haven't had time to adapt to this this
new very dangerous drug
another safety feature that alcohol has
always come with is social drinking
historically private access to alcohol
was unheard of if you wanted to drink
alcohol you were drinking it socially
communally there are often taboos
against drinking alcohol on your own
residents you had to drink it publicly
in ancient greece the symposium the the
wine
gathering was run by a symposiaric who
controlled the consumption of the
alcohol they would they would mix the
water and wine they'd make it stronger
or weaker depending on how drunk people
seemed and you only drank when it got
passed around
in ancient china and actually today in
china you don't drink it will you drink
when someone makes a toast
so when someone makes a toast you say
ganbai and you drink and then you have
to wait until someone makes a toast
again before you drink again it's a very
powerful way to control people's
drinking levels
even in very informal situations so you
think of yourself out with your friends
at a pub or at a dinner party
social control is very powerful at a pub
you finish your beer and you want
another one you have to wait until your
friends finish because you're going to
order another round
you're drinking too fast the cocktail
server doesn't make eye contact with you
you can't order another drink i start
helping myself to whine a little bit too
liberally at dinner and my mother-in-law
gives me a dirty look from across the
table
right we have all these ways of socially
regulating alcohol consumption and this
is a safety feature it's actually part
of how we've used alcohol
all of this goes out the door when you
have drive-through liquor stores you can
go through a drive-through liquor store
and load up your suv
with enough liquor to kill a
medium-sized village and just take it
home
it's this is evolutionarily
unprecedented and it's dangerous and of
course kovid made this so much worse
lockdowns made drinking at home
pathological and i think a lot of us are
still actually recovering from that
because alcohol is incredibly physically
addictive once you up your uptake it's
really hard to to tile it down again so
one take home message from the book is
beware of distilled liquors and don't
don't drink alone drinking alone is
really dangerous now that coveted
lockdowns are down we're all we're
meeting in person here we're all
drinking actually in public there's
there's a bartender who can look at you
and go no i'm not going to give you
another drink
take advantage of that drink one way to
mitigate the potential harms of alcohol
is to drink out with other people in
public so dionysus was worshiped by the
greeks as a god he gave these very
important gifts they viewed him with
caution as well and that's very
important we have to be cautious about
this this enabler of civilization
but the fact that intoxication and
civilization have been tied together so
tightly for so long gives us some sense
of why all cultures that i know of
have made a place for ecstasy and
intoxication in people's personal lives
and their social lives
and this is how we can continue i think
to thrive as the strangest primate in
the world but also the most effective
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
ted that was really great this question
of of whether or not this is a hijack or
a mismatch or an evolutionary mistake i
think is a it's an interesting one so
you're calling out both the mismatch and
the hijacking yes yeah i think they're
both wrong
and you just think it's just plain old
mistake and we're just too we're too
shortly into it
so i think they're both wrong because
the costs are so high that it doesn't
make sense that this mistake would be
allowed to stand by evolution there'd be
so much pressure to fix it and yet it
hasn't been fixed right even though we
have these solutions and i mean there's
a curious thing about this drug is that
it's um i mean it's gone in and out of
legality in many countries including
ours but i mean there's you know there's
clearly there's other
psychoactives that um that in some cases
i mean people can argue are better or
worse i mean it's very rare that someone
gets you know stoned on cannabis and
beats their family whereas they will do
this on alcohol
um i mean what's your take on you know
the alcohol substitutes of the world
yeah so in the book i do discuss other
intoxicants and i argue that there's a
reason that alcohol is that i call it
the king of intoxicants
if you gave
engineering a cultural engineering team
the task of coming up with the substance
and you gave them design specs we wanted
to be easy to make out of it anything it
should have predictable effects short
half-life predictable across individuals
they would probably come up with alcohol
so if you look at cannabis cannabis has
advantages
it doesn't lead to violence
it's not physically addictive it's
possibly psychologically addictive not
physically
it's physiologically less harmful than
alcohol
but it has wildly varying effects on
individuals so i have friends i had
friends in grad school here in the bay
area who would smoke and then go out
dancing
which is inconceivable to me so when i
smoke cannabis i get really paranoid and
then i fall asleep
so it's not a social drug for me you
can't your your social go-to drug can't
be something that has such variable
effects on people and it's also
hard to dose if you don't know how to
hold it in your lungs you don't get the
same dose whereas when we're all sipping
that beer or the georgian wine we know
what we're getting and we know and it
gets cleared from our body very quickly
because we have this machinery that's 10
million years old to grab that ethanol
break it down and get it out of our
bodies as quickly as possible yeah i
mean i think that's interesting i i have
noticed that you know certainly as
cannabis has become legalized that the
ability to dose it more
regularly you know it used to be like
you just got pot from your deal it was
just like no idea and so now you can go
to the store and it's like going to the
apple store and you like tell them that
you like long walks on the beach you
want to go to sleep when you dig it and
they like they like give you some nice
edible gummy and and it's a very
different thing so in some ways maybe
possibly the legality of things can make
them vastly more predictable and yeah
it's still individual variation i've
gone to cannabis shops and they've said
this will make you want to dance oh
you've just had the wrong strains you've
been having something that's too much
indica you need more sativa and like all
right i'll try that and i get really
paranoid to fall asleep so
there just is it just is the case that
that drug
the way it impacts your brain there's a
lot more individual variation i talk
about psychedelics in the book
psychedelics the problem with them is
they're so powerful right if we were all
doing mushrooms this would be a very
different scene right now right we just
don't do that
because they really powerfully
dissociate you from reality if you could
actually dose them in a different way so
you can separate the active component
you can put a little capsule maybe it
could actually be used the way that
alcohol is used
but our history with micro dosing is
10 years old
and our history with alcohol is at least
20 000 probably a lot longer so um i
like the tried and true technology
yeah
well i thought it was really interesting
this idea of booze as both the
the truth maker and the and the lie
detector and i think we've all
experienced you know in some cases maybe
people
giving too much truth when they're
intoxicated
and then and then also people realizing
someone's lying when they're intoxicated
uh and maybe kind of
that kind of breaks the social contract
uh in some ways as well i mean like the
office christmas party that yeah things
go too far right is this is this thing
and so i think that's it's an
interesting paradox it can both help
help a social contract and also hurt the
social contract it could hurt it though
in ways that are helpful because often
what that's bringing to the surface is
tensions that were really there
so it can help you actually break out of
kind of unhealthy relationships or
supposedly cooperative relationships
that are not really cooperative right
but i think it's sometimes on the office
party problem it's like maybe you want
to hold those things at bay gym in
accounting you should probably not
tell the ceo what he really thinks about
his new car yeah yeah and i think it's
interesting that you point out some of
the the civilizations that have have
developed the social different types of
social contract around alcohol the asian
cultures like i mean in japan like you
never pour your own drink
somebody else pours it for you and
however i've never really seen that as a
limiting factor in that japanese culture
but but i mean i think that may have
been what it was about um and even the
term bar
came from barring you from getting
substance that's useful but it's
dangerous
and so we come up with strategies to
mitigate its harm and one of those
strategies is always drink socially
and and social drinking in most cultures
is so surrounded with with ritual and
all sorts of regulations
it's really it's a safety feature it
allows you to consume
it
if you as an individual so when i was
coming home from going to the states
during coveted lockdowns and i was you
know in my apartment for two weeks and i
could call up my local taqueria and get
you know some carne asada delivered and
also as much tequila as i wanted that's
really dangerous if you're asking me as
an individual alone in my apartment to
regulate my alcohol consumption
i wouldn't put a i wouldn't bet on me
um but if i'm out in public with my
friends and my family and we're drinking
together and people are regulating me in
both conscious and unconscious ways that
helps so the the humans have developed
this kind of social safety net to help
us consume alcohol safely and that's why
i think that this this trend toward
drinking alone you know kind of suburban
american life where you instead of going
to the pub after work as you would in
europe or the cafe
where there's kids there's old people
everyone's there everyone's drinking
moderately you go home and you have
access to your liquor cabinet and as
much wine as you want
um we're not designed for that right
that's the mistake that's a mistake yeah
yeah that was never never part of the
plan evolutionarily yeah and i mean and
speaking of that and so this will be the
last question i asked before going to
the audience here for some questions um
so please raise your hand um and we'll
get a mic to you but um i think one of
the things that and i remember lance the
head distiller at st george who made
these spirits for us um that he you know
he looks at distillation as effectively
you know preserving a moment in time
um and a you know a particular
bill of of ingredients that can then
last effectively in perpetuity and i
think clearly there was some part of of
using alcohol as a preservation of
calories like you can't you know they
couldn't preserve grain without
refrigeration and other things all the
way through all their winter so actually
if you if at least it's part of your
calorie intake it's a way of of of
getting calories all the way
through preservation not just for the
drinking part yeah absolutely so you
know i dismissed the mismatch theories
because i don't think any of them can be
the whole story but they could be part
of the story so there's um the
biological and noblemen argument that
when you take grain and ferment it into
beer you're adding micronutrients and
that's probably one of the explanations
why people living in let's say ancient
egypt could live on these incredibly
monotonous diets they're moving from
being hunter-gatherers where they had
meat and vegetables and all the fruit
and now they're just eating bread that's
all they have is bread and water and
beer
and so beer is giving them these really
crucial micronutrients that help
and as you said you know there's a you
have this excess harvest you need to
store it somehow
beer and wine are good ways to do that
distillation is an awesome way to do it
because it lasts for so much longer and
was that also a way that people used to
in some way um
fight their own microbial battle within
their
with the food that they ate
yeah so there's the when you ferment if
you take water that's contaminated and
you ferment it it becomes potable
so the the dirty water hypothesis as i i
call it in the book has certainly got
got to be part of the story um but the
the problem with that as a soul
explanation is that a lot of cultures
that um drink alcoholic beverages mix it
with raw untreated water or they drink
both
or you have cultures like china where so
if the problem is dirty water
boil it
and china has had tea and this kind of
taboo against drinking unboiled water
for as long as we know and yet they're
still drinking lots of alcohol so that
can't be the only part of the story but
i think a lot of these mismatch
hypotheses
are feeding into the other kind of
social function right they can be yes
and not exclusive yeah do you have a
question anyone
[Music]
given the relationship the long-term
relationship with us and alcohol i was
wondering your thoughts
has evolution done the roi analysis and
realized alcohol is worth it
i think so because it both genetically
and culturally it was given and out
and it didn't take the out so i really
think that
the fact that we have these solutions
that have not spread
that have not reached fixation but still
hang around which is interesting in
itself
um suggests that there have to there has
to be countervailing positive benefits i
mean of course we're talking um in the
talk and now
we're giving intentionality to evolution
right it's a blind process
but it's it's the intentional language
is a helpful compression it's good for
humans to to reason with and so yeah i
think you know evolution basically
was has been aware of the cost but has
also been
not taken not made everyone have asian
flushing syndrome which is what it would
have done if it was all costs and no
benefits
interesting
yes
so other other animals lots of them
besides people
drink alcohol we've all seen pictures of
drunk elephants yeah i've watched wasps
going after downed fruit having trouble
flying afterwards and running into
things yeah so
how do you feel about
the extent to which this is not really
limited to to
peculiar eggs yeah so it
biologically ethanol
is a kind of pleasure lock it makes
lots of organisms feel good not just
humans what's different about humans is
we actually make alcohol and use it
consciously
elephants are not brewing things right
um so that's what's what's distinctive
about human beings is other and and
other species discover this typically
through us
so the
um the the
myths about like um
elephants getting drunk on wild
fermenting fruit someone did a study
just with a body weight of an elephant
like how much fermented fruit you would
need it's like a football stadium full
of fruit it's just not possible if
they're drunken elephants they've broken
into distilled liquors that humans have
made
so we're the ones who make this stuff
and make it available on a
intent in an intense way and on in a
widespread way
and consciously
as a tool
interesting you have any other questions
yeah you mentioned that um we're sort of
at like the most dangerous
part of in history and i was just
thinking about like do you think that is
going to continually get more dangerous
or less dangerous and why
it may get less dangerous if we discover
that micro dosing gives us all the
benefits and none of the costs
it might be less dangerous if we just
con
if we're aware of what the dangers are
we can design
social mechanisms that will help us
so we have you know humans have some
control over this but i think that the
problem is we've been when it comes to
alcohol we've been flying blind it's
just been like oh it's this thing fun
thing we do evolutionary mistake but
whatever we enjoy it
when we when we have a kind of muddled
way of thinking about alcohol it's hard
to make intelligent decisions i think if
we understand
what it's good for so what are the
functions that it serves
and we understand what the dangers are
so what happens when those functions
go over to the dark sides
when we're using distilled liquors or
we're blowing past 0.08 bac too fast we
can design um both alcohols
and and social mechanisms to help us and
i think i'm optimistic about humans i
think we're pretty good at figuring this
stuff out
so i mean you see this in in in the
craft beer industry you know there's a
long period where they're just pushing
for abv abv like making these like 12
percent abv beers
um and a lot of them have pulled back
and realized you know what actually the
reason people want to drink beer is they
want to sit with their friends and drink
and watch the game or chat
and to do that in a way that's
pleasurable you want a two to three
percent session now
um so we've all we've been able to kind
of
de-escalate
when we realize that it's not helpful
and so i think that but the crucial
thing is just knowing
having
a clear view of it and i think to have a
clear view of it we need to know our
history
we need to know our science
and we need to look at it all through an
evolutionary lens and a kind of long now
lens look at that on a large time scale
yeah and if any of you want to taste
some of these early
kind of recipes
there's patrick mcgovern which is one of
the people that you consulted a
biomedical archaeologist who's whose
main thing that he does is that whenever
they discover some tomb where there's a
burial that has like urns and things
like that he gets the scrapings of that
urn and he puts that through analysis
and figures out what was in it and then
he then works with make it
yeah and then he works with uh with
dogfish head brewery to create this
ancient ales collection and one of them
is the jiahu that's a 8 000 year old
recipe from asia one of them is midas
touch which is one that we used to serve
on on tap here um it's a very meat like
one but i would highly recommend it's a
great way to take a tour of some of the
oldest uh recipes on the planet they
make very limited runs of them but they
do it every year and you there's a whole
collection so i would recommend that i
guess the my question is like if we're
talking about evolution and alcohol is
do you think that there's going to be a
time when we like if it's if it has this
benefit
um do you think there's going to be a
time when we either evolutionarily or
through genetic engineering you know
basically develop better livers and
cancer resistance for the negative sides
yeah maybe maybe that's happened
maybe it's actually ongoing there's also
there's a interesting hypothesis that
um
so distillation first happened in china
it happened several hundred years before
europe
and i do have some colleagues who feel
like the asian flushing syndrome is or
so it hung around for a really long time
for other adaptive reasons but it's now
expanding to japan and other places
because it's a response to distillation
right that was in the rice wines the
early rise ones yeah yeah they were
distilling quite early make it sorghum
liquors um so it's possible that you
know maybe that's that genetic syndrome
will spread because maybe alcohol has
become too dangerous and we need to
flush and feel heart palpitations when
we have any of it right but so we can
you know this evolution keeps they could
be like the first
the first sign of that evolutionary
reaction yeah it's interesting thank you
so much
[Applause]